[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
مرحبا بدي للجميع الموجودين معنا اليوم
نعمل مع بعض انا واياكم تجربه عمليه بسيطه
بدل الجميع يرفع ايديك بهاي الحركه الي
نحن بنسميها حركه النصر الكل يعمل معي
بدنا ناخذ هدول الاصبعين ونحطهم بجانب
الحاجب رح تحسوا انه في فراغ بالضبط قد
حجم البصمتين هدول الكل يحس معي
في منكم راح يحس بنط وفي منكم راح يحس
براحه هاي النقطه احنا بنسميها نقطه
العلاج اللي مسؤوله عن تخفيف الالام لما
نحس ان راسنا بيوجعنا بعيده عن المفكره
عن هذا الموضوع اكثر واكثر في البدايه
احنا جميعا نتعرف
لازمات مواقف صعبه
بتولدنا افكار ومشاعر سلبيه او ممكن هذه
الافكار
والمشاعر السلبيه تاثر عليك وانا وحده من
هذول الاشخاص اللي كنت وانا صغير دائما
اشعر بالقلم والتوتر ليوم من الايام قررت
اني انهي كل هذه المشاكل ما لناش اضحك
ادور على الحل نهائي حكيت مع امي مع مرشده
المدرسه مع اي حدا ممكن يساعدها شويه شويه
وانا بادور شفت على الانترنت شيء اسمه
تقنيه
استغربت اولها كثير وصرت احكي شو هاي
التقنيه وعنجد بدها تساعدني وتلاقي الحل
واخلص من كل الالام وكل المشاكل اللي في
حياتي
شوي شوي بلشت اقرا عنها واكثر واكثر عشان
اشوف قديش فعاله من الناحيه الايجابيه في
حياتك ازاي يومها قررت اني ادخل دوره
الاكسس سبورت عشان اشوف عنها اكثر واكثر
في بدايه الدوره حكيت لنا معلمه الاكسسوار
عن قانون مهم في حياتك وهذا القانون اسمه
اسال تعطى
وشو بدنا نقطه بدنا نسال الكون الواسع عن
المشكله اللي احنا من واجهها في حياتنا
لانه الكون راح يستقبل هاي المشكله اللي
سالنا اياها بصيغه السؤال
ويعطينا الجواب يا بشائر او دلائل او اي
شيء يستاهلنا فمثلا اسال نفسك قبل اي عمل
ماذا يمكنني ان اقوم او افعل او اصنع
لاحسن حياتك وهو
بيبلش الكون بالتحرك والشوق لا يفرجيك
ثواب سؤالك مشكلتك
شوي شوي بلشنا نعرف عن تقنيه الاسس
وعرفنا انهم 32 نقطه كل نقطه الها اسم
معين في مجالات الحياه وكل نقطه تحتوي على
مسار طاقي غير مرئي هذا المسار الطاقي
اللي بيخزن جميع الافكار والمشاعر السلبيه
اللي من واجهها في حياتنا
كمتدربين في تقنيه الانثى سبايك بنضغط على
هدول النقاب لمده خمس دقائق لقى عيد
تفعيلها ونعيد ونحررها
من كل الافكار
والمشاعر السلبيه اللي مخزنه داخلها ونخلي
النصارى الطاقي يتدفق بشكل اكبر اوسع ونحس
بالراحه بشكل اعمق هون انا بلشت اطبق هاي
التقنيه عشان اشوف هل عنجد هي حقيقه ولا
بس تجربه شوي شوي يوم بعد يوم من تطبيق
لهذه التقنيه كثير بحرك من النتائج اللي
غيرت حياتي لما ضغطت حاجتك الابداع ونقطه
المال والثراء ونقطه التحكم
تفكير بتاعك اكثر واكثر
اخذ اي قرار بدي اياها
انا هون كنت كثير مبسوطه اني ساعدت نفسي
لاتخلص من كل المشاكل اللي واجهتها ومن
كتر ما انا كنت مبسوطه
ابلش ابحث عن اي حدا عشان اساعده اطبق له
هذه التقنيه بلشت عن عائلتي واصدقائي وكل
معهم وشوي شوي شوي اجى هم صار يحكوا لي
شكرا كثير احنا مستنيين لك سنه نقدر نعمل
اي شيء بسلام هدوء سبنا ننام نوم عميق نحس
بكل لحظه خلصنا من الاكتئاب والتوتر
والحجر للفرح والسعاده والسلام انا اهو
كنت كثير مبسوطه وشوفنا الفرق فعلا
180 درجه
وبالنهايه بحب احكي لكم ما تخلوا اي حدا
يؤثر عليكم بافكار او مشاعر سلبيه كونوا
واثقين بانفسكم ما تخلوا اي شيء يسكر انتم
قادرين على تحقيق المعجزات
تمتعوا بصحه وسلام وهدوء شكرا كثير لحسن
استماعكم
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]